على الجبهات الاوكرانيه الجيش الروسي لا
يقاتل وحده بل الى جانبه قوات غير نظاميه
ابرزها ميليشيا فاجنر
توزيع الجبهات بين القوات النظاميه وتلك
التي تعتمد حرب عصابات انعكس في خلافات
على مستوى قياداتها خصوصا بين وزير الدفاع
ورئيس مجموعه فاجنر فكيف تتقاسم القوات
المقاتله الجبهات
تقدر اجهزه استخبارات غربيه عدد عناصر
مجموعه فاجنر العامله في اوكرانيا بخمسين
الف مقاتل كان هذا العدد في بدايه الحرب
لا يتجاوز 10,000 عنصر هم جنود وضباط
سابقون ومقاتلون مخضرمون
لكن الظروف المعركه على الارض وبعد ان
بدات كفتها تميل لصالح كييف دفعت مؤسسه
المجموعه
كما تقول التقارير الغربيه الى تجنيد
عشرات الالاف من السجون الروسيه بصفقه
بسيطه الحريه في مقابل القتال سته اشهر
على الجبهه وفي الوقت الذي واجه فيه الجيش
الروسي عثرات في حربه على اوكرانيا كانت
قوه فادنر اكثر نجاعه رغم قله عدد افرادها
ويعود هذا حسب خبراء الى اعتناق الجيش
الروسي العقيده القتاليه الشرقيه
التقليديه التي تعتمد على فتح جبهات واسعه
وتكثيف العمليات القتاليه والعمل بمنطق
الموجات البشريه لكن هذه الاستراتيجيه لم
تكلل بالنجاح بدليل الفاتوره البشريه
الكبيره في صفوف القتلى من الجيش الروسي
التي يقدرها حلف شمال الاطلسي باكثر من
200 الف قتيل بالاضافه الى تراجع الجيش
الروسي وانتكاساته في كل من كييف وخركي
فيما تعتمد مجموعه
اهداف محدده وتركيز المجهود العسكري عليها
كما حدث في سوليدار ويحدث الان في بخمت
وقبلها
وتعمد المجموعه ومقاتلها الى قطع طرق
الامداد والمواصلات والقصف المركز
والاستعانه بالحركه السريعه لمقاتلها يضاف
الى هذا عامل مهم وهو تحفز مقاتليها
واندفاعهم للقتال